a high chance for Paul Kelso Sky News
you've talked about honesty and you've
talked about brexit the reality of
brexit for many companies is delays red
tape additional costs they can't hire
the people they want to come to this
country and you can't stop the people
you don't want to come to this country
would it not be more honest to
acknowledge that brexit is failing on
its own terms for business and those
terms need to be readdressed no and I
think if you look at the facts our
growth has been as I said in the speech
about the same as Germany since the
brexit referendum it's a big change in
our economic relations with our closest
neighbors and of course that is going to
need adaptation and of course there is
some short-term disruption but I think
it's completely wrong to just focus on
that without looking at the
opportunities for example in the Autumn
statement the solvency II reforms which
are only possible because of regulatory
flexibilities that we wouldn't have had
inside the EU mean that we will unlock
potentially over a hundred billion
pounds of investment into the industries
represented by people in this room
so in the end brexit is a choice it's an
opportunity
and we can make it an incredible success
and I believe we will